hoy en nuestra sección de salud tenemos
un tema que tiene que ver directamente
con la salud de las mujeres y para eso
nos acompaña a nuestra periodista
especializada en salud más Romero Mar
buenos días Buenos días María Clara
empecemos en India porque Un gobierno
regional adoptó la baja por dolores
menstruales Qué significa esto es una
baja laboral precisamente eso por los
dolores provocados por el periodo y fue
en el estado de querala en el sur de la
India es una medida totalmente pionera
porque muy pocos países que la tienen
estamos hablando de zambia Indonesia
Japón Corea del Sur y en Europa el único
es de España en el continente americano
no hay ninguno fue iniciativa además de
un sindicato estudiantil que defendía
que había estudiantes que estaban
perdiendo clase debido a esto y que se
les contaba como faltas de asistencia Y
esa iniciativa se transformó en una
medida de carácter regional para todo el
estado de querala este tipo de medidas
suelen ser controvertidas Porque algunos
defienden que es garantizar más derechos
para las mujeres permitirles que puedan
pasar esos dolores menstruales y que no
se les castigue por trabajo pero por
otros hay quienes defienden que podría
aumentar ese estigma de que las mujeres
no son capaces de hacer el mismo trabajo
o que pues sufren más digamos y que
entonces eso afecta en que las contraten
menos y en medio de esta controversia se
suele pormenorizar o pasar desapercibido
ese dolor de las mujeres Cuál es la
realidad en cifras del dolor menstrual
claro vamos a ir a los números de la
dismenorrea que es el nombre digamos
médico para los dolores menstruales
vemos que es absolutamente prevalente
entre las mujeres y todas las personas
que menstrúan según cifras recogidas en
Estados Unidos entre el 45 y el 95%
experimentan Esta dismenorrea es decir
en el mejor de los casos es
prácticamente la mitad de las personas y
además entre el 20 y el 25% sufren unos
dolores de gravedad suficiente para
interferir en sus actividades diarias es
decir discapacitante esto es entre una
de cada cinco o una de cada cuatro
personas importante también decir esta
dismenorrea dos tipos la primaria
digamos que son los dolores que vienen
directamente causados por el pedido
periodo por las contracciones del útero
por las cambios fisiológicos en el
cuerpo durante este momento pero luego
hay ladiorrea secundaria que es cuando
el periodo duele por alguna otra causa
por ejemplo endometriosis síndrome de
ovarios poliquísticos hay varias de las
que podríamos hablar y precisamente para
no pormenorizar como estabas diciendo tú
el dolor menstrual es muy importante
recordar el dolor de la regla no es
normal no es algo lo que deberíamos
estar acostumbradas No deberíamos tener
que estarnos medicando cada mes para
poder venir a trabajar entonces Si eso
sucede consulten con especialistas y
ojalá también Algún día nos podamos
pedir una baja si lo necesitamos bueno y
hablando de lo que ocurre en los
trabajos hablemos un poco de qué pasa
con estas personas que madrugamos tan
temprano porque hay un nuevo estudio que
relaciona la falta de sueño con la
esclerosis múltiple si es un estudio del
instituto carolinska de Suecia y se
centra en la falta de sueño en adoles
Aunque tú y yo ya no seamos adolescentes
sigue siendo igual de importante dormir
bien la principal conclusión es que
dormir menos de siete horas diarias
entre los 15 y los 19 años aumenta en un
40% el riesgo de aparición de esclerosis
múltiple los datos No son suficientes
para establecer una causa digamos no
podemos decir que dormir mal hace Que
aparezca la enfermedad pero sí para
establecer la relación entre estos dos
factores digamos que la esclerosis
múltiple es un trastorno Además del
sistema inmune que ataca a la cubierta
de las células nerviosas del cerebro de
la médula espinal que se llama mielina
Por cierto y Pero además el sueño está
muy asociado con el sistema inmune Esta
es una causa que sabemos desde hace
tiempo una relación que se conoce desde
hace tiempo por eso podría ser plausible
digamos esa relación entre los dos cosas
Bueno y usted también así un poco un
llamado a la calma que esto no significa
que necesariamente las personas van a
padecer esta enfermedad cuéntenos qué
tan fiable es el estudio sí como siempre
aquí que hacemos nuestros checkings
vamos a decir de qué sesgos padece el
estudio para tener claro y poder cogerlo
también con la precaución que es
necesaria el principal sesgo es que es
un estudio hecho en retrospectiva no las
personas con esclerosis múltiple dicen
cómo dormían en esa edad entonces hay un
sesgo y pues que puede ser de recuerdo
de percepción no de cómo estaba en ese
momento luego también hay muchas cosas
que pueden influir tanto en la
enfermedad Como en el dormir o mal hay
muchas causas ambientales dormir mal
está relacionado con otros malos hábitos
de salud con problemas también en la
Salud Mental la esclerosis múltiple está
relacionada por ejemplo con otros tipos
de dolencias como el virus epstein bar
que es el que provoca la Perdón la
enfermedad del beso que se me acaba de
olvidar Cómo se llama de forma digamos
un poquito más formal pero digamos que
también si recogemos las opiniones que
han dicho los científicos los neurólogos
al respecto vemos una opinión recogida
por Science media Center de Ana Belén
caminero que es neuróloga y que dice que
pese a estos sesgos que siguen
existiendo como decíamos hay una
plausibilidad biológica para pensar con
sueño insuficiente y de mala calidad
puede aumentar el riesgo de esta
enfermedad entonces bueno digamos que de
adolescentes y ahora también todos
tenemos que dormir bien porque como
usted lo dice la falta de sueño nos
afecta a todos Así no se vamos
adolescentes más así no seamos
adolescentes lastimosamente
lastimosamente Bueno yo no estoy tan
triste de no ser adolescente más gracias
por este segmento de salud gracias a